[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette
première édition 2020 d'espèces
autochtones en direct je m'appelle
anne-marie yvan on a décidé de commencer
cette nouvelle année
en parlant des enfants d'ailleurs on en
a parlé beaucoup aussi en 2019 c'est
l'avenir c'est notre avenir et les
autochtones vous le savez ils sont
nombreux les enfants on aime les enfants
on prend soin des enfants et on prend
soin d'eux entre autres lorsque la
famille la famille principal ne peut pas
le faire si les autochtones c'est une
coutume qui dure depuis des milliers
d'années on appelle ça l'adoption
coutumières et c'est le sujet que nous
allons aborder aujourd'hui avec nos
invités
alors isabelle picard bonjourbonjour
bonne année isabelle qui n'est pas une
invitée qui est notre chroniqueuse
régulière avec vos isabelle on va parler
d'adoption coutumière mais comment elle
se déroulait il ya plusieurs centaines
vous allez peut-être surpris parce que
je vais vous apprendre d'accord
également tom croft et hommes qui
étaient déjà venus à l'émission au
printemps de l'année dernière pour
parler des métiers non traditionnels et
vous êtes une famille non traditionnels
ou ceux chez vous prions donc trois
enfants trois enfants adoptés ouais deux
trois façons différentes tout à fait cet
original 3 ça nous plaît on va en parler
bonne année teyton mon âne à toi et puis
eva ottawa
eva ottawa qui est attikamek de manouane
eva ottawa qui vient d'être nommé
professeur à l'université d'ottawa
félicitations et va merci et bonne année
ça va être une année importante pour
vous là oui oui une belle bella mais
avec des nouveaux défis ou et d'ailleurs
les défis vous en avez relevé plusieurs
on va quand même mentionné que vous avez
été à la tête du conseil de la nation
atikamekw le sénat pendant quoi
plusieurs années 2006 à 2013 un demande
de 1 to 1 7 1 oui c'est ça exactement
ensuite vous avez été aussi la première
femme autochtone au conseil du statut de
la femme
ça c'était en 2007
et puis hélas c'était tout récent en
décembre vous avez reçu la médaille
premiers peuples remise par le
lieutenant gouverneur du québec pour
votre application dans le milieu
autochtone
oui oui exactement vous vous ennuyez pas
dans la vie non et en plus d'être nommé
professeur et c'est pour ça qu'on vous a
évité par ce que vous faites votre
maîtrise sur l'adoption coutumière chez
les attikameks oui j'ai été approché par
l'université d'ottawa au printemps 2007
parce qu'il y avait un environnement le
projet de loi qu'on appelait 113 à
l'époque où ils reconnaissent l adoption
coutumière voilà faits qui m'ont
approché pour faire une des études
supérieures faire une maîtrise hors j'ai
choisi l'adoption coutumière justement
dans ce contexte d'accord et donc depuis
juin 2018 ce n'est plus un projet de loi
c'est la loi 113 qui s'applique au
québec incite au québec seulement c'est
une loi provinciale alors d'entrer deux
jours expliqué c'est quoi l'adoption
coutumière chez les autochtones qui
voudrait répondre qui se sont le plus
apte à répondre à cette vaste question
oui ben moi j'ai fait mon projet de
recherche a man wan dans chez moi je
suis originaire belge résidant dans la
communauté je suis membre la communauté
de manouane et le terme qu'on utilise et
au bicross swing c'est le fait de
prendre en charge un enfant puis de le
guider de l'amener à maturité avec moi
j'ai décidé de documenter de rencontrer
des personnes qui ont vécu
personnellement un hobby cran souhaité à
titre d'enfant de parents d'origine ou
de parent gardien
ok pour les gens de manouane med mais
chez les attikameks l'adoption
coutumière fonctionne de la même manière
pour tout le monde
moi j'ai décidé d'y aller je savais
qu'une communauté ce n'est plus facile
plus moins loin ou si loin la proximité
mais je pense qu'il ya des choses qui
peuvent être transposable aux deux
autres
deux autres communautés étaient d'accord
mais vous m'expliquez avant qu'on arrive
sur le plateau que l'adoption coutumière
fonctionne différemment d'une nation à
notre jeune comme lui n'ont eu d'autre à
londres non mais doit pas y avoir des
six grandes différences non bah ça je
peux pas ce soir j'ai regardé la matinée
au niveau des autres comme chez nous et
nous et tout signe comment ça se faisait
il y avait quand même beaucoup de choses
qui se ressemblent à jouer
c'est quand même dingue moi j'aime mieux
le mettre dans le contexte de manouane
oui d'accord moi ok alors on va y aller
avec un exemple concret parce que tu es
tome vous avez l'expérience dans le dans
le domaine vous avez adopté trois
enfants tout à fait j'ai trois enfants
de trois communautés différentes et vous
les avez adopté de trois manières
différentes allant expliquez nous le
premier en fait l'organe que 9 ans lui
jamais adoptée de la dpj bacio j'étais
en processus pour familles d'accueil
je te familles d'accueil dans le feu
puis c'est bon tu mixes donc c'est un
enfant qui était jumelé avec moi dans le
bus où ce qu' on puisse l'adopter
et puis je les ai eus pendant trois ans
attitude de famille d'accueil oui et
puis après on a fait le processus
d'adoption donc c'est toute la
bureaucratie qui est long et puis il est
adopté officiellement on est en 2009 en
2010 alors logo nuit vient de lac simon
ouais il vient de l'acsm ans après j'ai
eu patricia parce que je la voir une
fille non que patricia qui vient dodgers
rêveur qui est inuit elle je lui à 18
mois est la leur à la 5ème jour d'hui on
est toujours en processus est toujours
un enfant qui place six magie
juridiction dans le fond le basket en
famille d'accueil
mais on a tout un processus pour
l'adoption éventuelle
donc quand on est en famille d'accueil
c'est par la dpj que ça se passe tout à
fait un pur pour les deux plus vieux oui
tandis que frédéric la différence est
que d'ici là plusieurs c'est ma plus
jeune elle c'est vraiment une adoption
coutumier ce qui est arrivé c'est que ma
mère est évident qu'en noir et puis
c'est la famille
qu'ils approchaient ma mère parce que
bon il voyait les photos de mes enfants
puis bon je ne connaissais via les
réseaux sociaux
et puis la mer à voulait avoir quelqu'un
qui puisse donner une meilleure vie de
meilleure qualité de vie à sa fille
et puis à l'approché maman puis elle m'a
mis en contact avec pendant qu'elle
pensait donc qu'elle avait seymour quant
à me demander si je serai intéressé à
prendre son bébé oui elle a quel âge
aujourd'hui à la 2e année le zoo nuit
donc elle est arrivée dans votre famille
elle avait sept mois non est arrivé dans
ma famille à la v8 jo 8,5 de cet accord
de sept mois tout au long du processus à
me donner à me donnait l'ailé et les
échographies le processus commence à
fonctionner avec la sage femme et tous
puis au moment où ce qu'elle a accouché
ma mère est allée parce que ça se passe
avec une sage-femme et puis à 3 heures
du matin j'ai eu l'appel comme quoique
fallait je donne un nom et ma fille
oui mais j'étais comme dans le déni
parce que je me disais un cookie avoir
couché c'est impossible que abandonné
son bébé si je me suis dit on va vouloir
le garder donc je tape sur le fait que
jeter comme un peu réservé je n'avais
pas vraiment donné non à mon enfant oui
et puis ça s'est passé assez rapidement
finalement alors elle vient de saint
louis dont c'est une petite inouk aussi
oui mais donc adopté de façon coutumière
tout à fait est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il ya moins de paperasse à remplir
quand on fait ça c'est quoi la
différence à vous l'avez vécu de trois
manières différentes c'est quoi la
grande différence en fait ça a été un
peu plus lent par rapport à justement
parce que ce qui est à lui et c'est
qu'il y ait fallu que quand la mère est
arrivée ici on n'a pas seulement un
auteur pour me donner parce que j'adore
voyager donc je voulais avoir les autres
l'autorisation de voyager avec ma fille
quitte et puis ce soit plus l'industrie
aussi au niveau médical parce que
ma fille elle était malade un peu donc
est important pour moi d'avoir de
prouver que c'est moi qui ai la mer que
c'est mon enfant oui donc ça a été assez
lent et puis je vous dirais que
dernièrement le gouvernement parce que
j'ai prouvé au gouvernement qui est bon
c'est en fait elle est avec moi depuis
large de vie jo et puis là j'ai été
capable d'avoir les allocations
familiales mais ils reconnaissent pas
parce que au début et on la dpj du 208
millions faite comme ça comme si à la
barre de 9 sont en fait ma se tapent à
un corps de se taper un code 2d pj donc
que falluja a pris 14 mois avant que
jane lot comme quoi que c'est un point
co2 dpj donc elle avait fait l'adoption
si c'était vraiment l'adoption
coutumière m avait donné son âge
donc soit il a fallu puis ça a été non
d'avoir ce papier le coup juste à papier
le là c'est un moment là j'ai pu aller
d'un marchand gouvernement oui j'imagine
qu'il ya cent ans on n'y avait pas de
papiers ont donné un enfant ça change un
peu les choses c'est de l'adoption
coutumière mais il ya quand même des
règles légales à suivre qui peuvent être
compliqué non mais comme on parlait de
la notion d' abandon je pense que c'est
important pour les attikameks de
manouane ça a été un répéter mène au
niveau des meilleurs leur apport qui a
sorti en 2012 puis même dans les données
c'est pas une abondance et un don oui
enfin ça c'est important
puis de le faire ou si haut niveau à
verbal oralement de demander ce soit les
dents les données que j'ai eu c'est soit
les grands-parents la grand mare qui
faisaient équipe entre prenait
l'initiative one la mer les parents et
la présence des grands parents étaient
importantes dans wii alors tom vous
disiez que bon le jour de la naissance
vous
dit peut-être qu'il va vouloir le garder
est ce qu'elle aurait pu le garder je te
fais tout à fait écoute
j'étais vraiment étonné donc c'est un
moment là j'ai demandé j'ai demandé
comment quelqu'un à marie sa fille n'ont
qu'à me dit qu'il donnerait le nom d'
eva qui était sa grand mère qui était
une personne qui a travaillé beaucoup
pour les droits humains
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai nommé
frédéric eva et le tchouk c'est vraiment
son lit donc pour moi c'est un manque de
respect puis j'ai toujours dit que à
chaque fois que la famille de saint lô
sud ne m'ont rien jamais je vois
empêcher mais enfin d'avoir leurs
familles parce que pour moi c'est
important
c'est important qu'ils connaissent douce
qui viennent dont ils ont qu'à chaque
fois que la famille de ça mais je me
déplace puis je veux voir la famille et
c'est ça le but aussi de l'adoption
coutumière celle de ne jamais briser le
lien entre l'enfant et sa famille ça
serait important c'est le maintien du
lien de filiation qui même les contacts
ou suivre oui c'est encourager c'est
comme donner même les enfants les dames
qui utilise pour désigner la famille et
les parents le parent adoptif qu'on veut
dire pis même au niveau des autres ça
ressort adoptif ça va être les mêmes des
remords ni musée ni même taille
quand c'est naturel loi de say say say
est important de maintenir et ce qui
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui la mer et peut
pas changer d'idée la pourrait pas
revenir chercher la petite
en fait je crois que oui je pense qu'à
pourrait mais en fait ça serait je pense
pas que je pense pas qu'elle ferait
parce que justement à la voiture
anna j'ai envoyé des photos puis vlc que
cet enfant l'eau j'ai jamais je voyais
empêché parce qu'elle est déjà venu au
sud puis juste aller la voir avec
l'enfant oui jamais je voyais empêché
parce que c'est quand même la mère
biologique elle me fait un beau cadeau
en moins c'est hyper important mais
aussi avoir la tâche mac sa fille
biologique qu'elle a envers moi aussi
c'est la fusion est lourdingue et donc
ccsa pour réalité frédéric c'est à voit
qu'il ya une ressemblance au fca
comprend pas le deux ennemis mais plus
tard d'avoir comprendre ce mais pour le
moment qu'à la voix est comme moi qui
étais tu es qui m e essai qui aurait
très très collée sur moi mais c'est
normal
oui oui je vois et va agir il atteignait
ce tantôt par rapport aux de revenir sur
la décision parce que moi je moi même
j'ai eu un un colloque est ce qu'elle
est les parents le père et la mère ayant
décidé de donner l'enfant de faire un
don de leur enfant à naître
et il y avait eu beaucoup d'inquiétudes
l'eau de la mer adoptif mais pour la
mère d'origine
elle disait qu'il y avait pris la
décision c'est le principe de l'honneur
vous s'il vous arrive on respecte ayons
décidé ils vont l'enfant vont être
placés dans la famille vont maintenir
des contacts qui vont savoir basque à
l'effet qu'ils vont pouvoir le suivre
c'est c'est ce qui est important
oui s est ce que les les deux autres
enfants de vos deux autres enfants
est-ce qu'ils ont accès à leurs parents
de la même manière ou puisque ça ne
s'est pas fait de la même façon je sais
pas c'est quoi la relation avec leurs
parents d'origine en fait
patricio oui
la mère biologique de sang nous on doit
on doit se présenter une fois par année
dans le grand nord pour maintenir la
culture donc c'est porter la dpj mais me
demander de me présenter donc c'est ce
que je fais à chaque set avec patricia 7
avec pâtissier patricia tandis que le
guen lui ça a été vraiment y'a pas la
chance de rencontrer ses parents par
contre vous savait instinctivement
c'est vraiment motivant ils gagnent mais
son pari et non déclarée sur le
baptistère puis bon mais moi mais j'ai
reconnu son père parce que c'était le
portrait craché sur h et puis je savais
puis cgg une discussion avec justement
le parent biologique est en passe de
porter car mon fils parce que j'ai dit à
mon fils je ne sais hyperimportant la
journée qu'elle soit vouloir savoir d'où
ce que tu viens soit comprendre est un
moment long pour pouvoir faire des
rencontres oui même on reste en deçà
biologique qui est adopté et sa soeur
biologique il la rend compte à toutes
les deux mois donc c'est hyper important
de maintenir le lien est de maintenir eu
la culture aussi tout allait chez les
attikameks en fait c'est la même chose
l'adoption coutumière avec la loi 113 la
dpj a quand même un droit de regard
comment ça fonctionne avec le lien avec
la dpj dans l'adoption coutumières au
niveau d'un manhwa mme c'est sûr avec la
loi qui a été adopté on se retrouve avec
trois régimes au niveau de l'adoption il
ya l'adoption légale l'adoption à
coutumières et tactiquement avec la loi
et le système coutumier et au niveau 2
des attikameks de manouane bâillon nommé
à une autorité compétente nous ont
demandé des personnes nous pour agir
comme un autorités compétentes qui a man
one c'est annette dubé et andré kitsch
qui ont été un homme et le pis les
dossiers ils sont acheminés sont ils
rentrent par les services sociaux
puis aux autres s'organisent pour les
transmettre
autorités compétentes parce que dans la
loi bassesse et à la loi sur la
protection de la jeunesse
il ya quand même mais je pense qu'il ya
comme un incitatif aussi nos clients qui
la question des déplacements ça fait
partie des plantes ville qu'on peut
considérer ici en tant que la dpj mais
faut que ça soit comme autorisé par le
dpj où va la protection de la direction
de la protection sociale au niveau des
attikameks mais le rôle précis de ces
autorités compétentes c'est quoi
exactement
ces deux personnes qui ont été nommées
avoir vérifié la silla la coutume
respecte mais les notions de l'intérêt
de l'enfant et de respecter le droit et
de recevoir les consentements des des
personnes non des parties concernées
ok donc les autorités compétentes elles
ont un rôle avant l'adoption une fois
qu'une fois l'adoption a eu lieu une
fois où ils l ont pu rien à voir dans le
dossier après l'adoption c'est ça après
l'adoption ni en europe après l'adoption
doivent vérifier si l'intérêt de
l'enfant et les respecter et à mes yeux
il doit vérifier ici si l'enfant n'y a
pas eu de signalement par rapport à
l'enfant ils doivent recevoir un avis
ils doivent vérifier auprès de la prison
de la protection sociale au niveau at-il
à m ah oui et hommes est ce que il y a
quelqu'un comme ça une autorité qui est
là pour vérifier que tout fonctionne
comme il se doit
non chez les inuit c'est pas comme ça
mais par contre avec la dpj oui la dpj
m'ont demandé je demande c'est hyper
important parce que yahoo beaucoup
d'enfants autochtones et nous est qu'ils
ont été émis avec des familles
allochtone donc officiel ayons une perte
d'identité donc c'était hyper important
de données d'identité à l'enfant puis
sentiment de fierté de qui sont enfin
chez moi mais
pour moi il n'y a pas de problème de ce
côté là justement la dpj m'a demandé de
donner des conférences au niveau des
familles parce que je sais c'est
important de casser enfants le plus déjà
qu'on les sorte de leur famille et puis
qu'on les envoie dans des familles
allochtone c'est important qu'ils
sachent d'où ce qui vient depuis c'est
quoi leur culture donc c'est de
transmettre s'appuie pour moi c'est
important donc à chaque fois que je
descends dans un grand nom
c'est ce que je disais tantôt à eva
j'étais allé voir comme un con con des
points forts parce que c'est important
pour moi de donner d'apprendre pour
donner à mes enfants plus tard parce
qu'on commence et je veux que mes filles
et mon fils wally l'idole de demain je
veux qu'ils soient fiers de kicks ans
puis que c'est important donc je sais ce
que je fais c'est mon devoir de le faire
bien sûr oui
isabelle chez les wade hâte à ce qu'on
pratique encore beaucoup l'adoption
coutume je me suis posé la question
pendant que j'écoutais puis à moncaut à
ma connaissance il n'y a pas beaucoup de
que dans les dernières années
il n'y a peut-être pas de l'adoption
coutumière mais souvent il va y avoir
des placements à long terme disons d'une
de la mère biologique avec l'attendu
dont la mère biologique ne peut pas s'en
occuper
donc ça va être la tendre qui va
s'occuper de l'enfant donc dans un
aspect je me lasse mal on sait ce que
c'est de la tutelle coutumière je sais
pas ce qu'on pourrait appeler ce plus
bas je sais qu'à val d'oise c'est le
même terme le seo by cros swing c'est le
fait de dindes et de guider l'enfant le
mois ces sept pilotes qui je pense n'a
pas été officiellement adopté mais vous
lis qu'on retrouva wendat qu'est-ce que
j'en connais quelques corps maintenant
il ya quand même quelque chose d'assez
intéressant pour les communautés dites
domiciliés c'est à dire les communautés
qui au 17e 18e 19e siècle avec des
missions chez un donc c'est à dire
lorette c'est un registre octobre avec
les algonquins les moquettes chéraga
narguer aussi oui
il y avait beaucoup des filles des
filles mères allochtone donc des
blanches qui venait porter leur enfant
illégitime sur les parvis de l'église
qui vont remonter à des mères ou à des
femmes autochtones pour que les femmes
autochtones puissent s'en occuper est ce
la tradition orale le raconte énormément
dans nos communautés
dès le xviie siècle donc mais quand même
ça fait quand même longtemps ils sont
neuf ce pendant plusieurs siècles dans
les communautés disons qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui plus urbaines qui sont
installés depuis longtemps autant chez
les abénakis que chez les années j'ai
nommé les algonquins au coq à l'époque
lé maroc matches et sera donc c'est
quand même intéressant on as existence
et l famille ben c'est pas tout à fait
et on sait qu évidemment un métissage
physique avec ces adoptions là puisque
dix ont une petite fille qui qui est
leur retrouvés sur le parvis de l'église
va être adoptée par une famille vont
grandir dans la culture wendat par
exemple et vous adoptez donc toutes les
coutumes les traditions dont le perlage
l'artisanat le rôle de la femme et que
j'étais rome mais maintenant quand on
est un vrai plus vieille elle va épouser
souvent un autochtone et donc il va y
avoir un métissage physique et ça va
contribuer à nous on voit aujourd'hui
comme réalité dans ces communautés
ça se faisait beaucoup ça se faisait
quand même assez pour que dans les
années 2000 on entende encore par oui
donc on sait que ça se faisait quand
même pas mal
et comment choisissait la famille
adoptive est en fait ce qu'on a entendu
et là encore là c'est du domaine de la
tradition orale you denis delage
l'historien qui en a parlé un petit peu
denses dans ses écrits dans ses travaux
mais pour le reste c'est la tradition
orale les familles autochtones et est
reconnu au 17e 18e 19e siècle comme
étant très bienveillants à l'égard des
enfants alors que changer bénin alors
que chez les européens la tradition
disons la place des enfants elle était
autrement peut se le cacher et donc
c'était vraiment réconfortant pour une
fille meure allochtone d'aller porter
son enfant
on savait que les femmes autochtones et
les familles et la communauté allait
bien prend soin de l'enfant
oui ça ne fait pas arrivé chez les
attikameks parce que vous étiez trop
loin trop loin
ses manières you quand même eu des
déplacements dans d'autres familles
aussi d'autres nations que sa gelée pas
documenté moi je me suis comme
concentrer sur les why we récents ceux
qui ont vécu personnellement me transmet
chez les seuls tours saskatchewan est ce
que ça aurait pu arriver ce qui avait
été revalorisée liens proches vous êtes
originaire de bain juste dans ma propre
famille je me souviens que ma tante a
été levée par ben en fait la seule maman
non en fait la ligne à 100 ma mère elle
est élevée par sa mère donc ces salariés
souvent encore aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup d'enfants qui sont qui d
adoption traditionnelle bourse bien oui
c'est ça même et que dd allochtone à
l'époque qui a trait au japon ainsi qu'à
ma vie a été proche c'est pas ça je peux
donner la main pour vous et parce que
j'ai grandi au québec donc oui ce
domaine j'en ai promis l'adoption
coutumière existe et où tafer ou est
exaucé encore et ça ça existe j'imagine
partout dans toutes les communautés
autochtones que ce soit au canada ou aux
états unis
un mâconnais saint louis c'est une
tradition qu'on voit un peu moins et
tout dans les écrits ouais lorsque j'ai
vu dans mes recherches aussi ça se fait
encore beaucoup comme chez les
attikameks mouvement n'est capable de
mettre des chiffres sur l'adoption
compteront en nombre de statistiques
comme tel mais je sais que quand j'ai
contacté quand j'ai parlé fait du
terrain ben après les entrevues les
participants y met d'antillais
facilement d'autres personnes qui
avaient vécu une aura qui avaient été
élevés par adoption ben pas par d'autres
clients
mais dans le cadre de vos recherches
pour votre maîtrise vous avez eu à
discuter donc avec des parents qui ont
fait le don de leurs enfants non est ce
qu'elle vous a vu des exemples oui j'ai
eu d'ailleurs j'ai eu des des parents
qui ont donné leurs
en fait dans de leurs enfants oui j'en
ai deux codes dans meilleur mes
recherches
est-ce que les raisons de le faire ont
évolué à travers le temps où on fait
toujours pour les mêmes raisons en
sachant qu'on va lui peut-être lui
donner une meilleure vie dans une autre
famille dans un code dans un des
meilleurs que j'ai eu c'est parce que la
mère eut la mère adoptive pouvait pas
avoir d'enfant fait que cela il en va
demander aux parents à la mère d'origine
de faire don de son enfant à cette
attente
alors c'est comme ça c'était comme
encourager pour aider des familles
d'aider des couples qui pouvaient pas
avoir d'enfant
cette année dans un autre costes parce
qu'il y avait déjà beaucoup d'enfants
puis il y avait des situations médicales
de certains enfants fait qu'ils ont
préféré le donner dans la famille de
regarder dans la famille pour alors à
une autre époque il y avait une autre
façon de faire de l'adoption l'adoption
de guerrière je l'appellerai hiver c'est
vraiment particulier vous à nous
apprendre des choses étonnantes est
assez surprenant si c'est la première
fois que vous allez en entendre parler
vous allez voir que vous allez peut-être
me dire waouh t'es sûr oui oui chose
certaine les relations des jésuites en
parle l'anthropologue bruce turgot on
parlera love you en parle également dans
ses livres est donc là on parle des
guerres de capture je sais pas si vous
en avez déjà entendu parler c'est
extrêmement intéressant
donc ce sont des guerres qui était fait
avant la colonisation mais aussi pendant
le contact et le j'y reviendrai donc on
voulait remplacer finalement des pertes
humaines au sein d'une communauté
en partant la guerre faisant des
prisonniers les ramenant et si ils
n'étaient pas soumis à la torture parce
que c'était aussi une des options il
pouvait à être adoptés et la remplacer
des gens qui au sein même de cette
communauté la étaient décédés pour des
raisons extra exode
bien sûr au niveau à quand il ya eu le
contact on se dit énormément d'épidémie
il ya eu des guerres notamment frank ou
iroquoise en nouvelle france qui ont
fait énormément de
deux décès et donc ces guerres de
capture là on était vraiment accentuée à
cette époque là c'était les moeurs de
clan notamment chez les européens donc
autant chez les wendat que j'ai dans la
confédération aux donations et qui
disait aux guerriers mau belhow vous
allez partir puis vous allez aller
chercher des hauts dirigeants
oui autant des jeunes des femmes que des
hommes et les ramener pour remplacer
ceux qui étaient morts soit à cause des
épidémies ou à cause des gays donc ça
c'est quand même intéressant
on dit même que chez les héros clients
particuliers ou chez les iroquois des
il y avait plus de captifs adopté au
sein des communautés que d'iroquois de
souche
donc ça c'est quand même intéressant ça
montre l'importance de ces gars là pour
remplacer finalement les défunts ce qui
est intéressant aussi c'est que bon il y
avait une espèce de testage on prenait
pas disons un jeune homme de 17 ans tout
de suite qu'on disait benoît anta diop
non non il y avait quand même on le
regardait faire on lui parlait on
l'étudié et finalement c'était les
femmes qui disaient oui on va l'adopter
et il y avait une cérémonie d'adoption à
ce niveau là on lui donner un nouveau
nom donc nouvelles et dans tout l'est
complètement et suite à cette personne
là avaient les mêmes droits et les mêmes
pouvoirs ou les mêmes responsabilités
que l'ensemble des autres membres du
clan n'est d'ailleurs même si un homme
pouvait remplacer une femme une femme
pouvait remplacer un homme dont qui
était mort donc ce n'était pas
nécessairement un homme qui remplaçait
un homme ou un jeune homme qui remplace
un jeune homme un jeune homme pouvait
remplacer une personne aînée et cette
personne mais souvent on ne le corps
dans les relations des jésuites d'un
jeune homme de 17 18 ans qui avait été
adoptée et qui devait remplacer un vieil
oncle un petit peu grotesque un petit
peu ridicule et il devait une fois de
temps en temps faire les mimiques de ce
vieil oncle dont on lui avait parlé dont
il a doté les mimiques un peu ridicule
vraiment pour vraiment rappeler qui il
était
cela pouvait aussi devenir des chefs de
guerre des chefs civils et maire de
clans ton cri pour prouver que
l'adoption elle était réelle parce que
pendant longtemps les spécialistes se
sont dit est-ce que c'était des vrais
adopté on se parle les historiens des
anthropologues ou est-ce que c'était
réellement
est-ce que c'était des esclaves donc
c'était un peu mais c'était la liesse
des sans consentement préalable mais
c'était une tradition qui étaient
respectés parce que ça se faisait des
deux côtés si je prends les wendat et
les iroquois entre autres donc ça se
faisait des deux côtés donc c'était
respecté par les gens qui étaient
capturés jusqu'à un certain point
ok mais on capture est des gens dans
toutes les autres nations hausse mais je
sais que ça se faisait beaucoup au
niveau des héros qu elle donc ça peut
faire oui entre donc comme je parle la
confédération wendat la confédération de
la journée ça se faisait aux etats-unis
aussi je peux pas dire à propos des
algues hockey parce qu'on n'a pas de dj
comme tsn attikameks passé par londres
donc ça c'est quand même intéressant
c'est cet aspect là qu'on connaît très
très peu mais qui était une forme
d'adoption vraiment connu et oui on ne
fait cependant plusieurs c'est qu'enfin
on sait pas depuis quand parce que la
tradition rendra compte que si je suis
des temps immémoriaux mais on sait pas
exactement depuis combien de temps le
taux s'est fait mais c'est vraiment bien
documenté c'est quand même intéressant
de voir ce remplacement là est toute la
place qu'on faisait à ces gens là dans
la communauté ont même fait que on
disait maintenant c'est mon frère se
massent à aller jusque là il y avait
vraiment une reconnais pas de traîtrise
nom de la balade preuve qu'on sache qui
est vous le disiez aussi même avec la
colonisation ça s'est poursuivi
est-ce que ça s'est poursuivi avec des
non autochtones on pouvait adopter un
prisonnier non à octobre pendant mes
recherches c'est parce que j'ai vu
c'était pas les mêmes traditions donc ça
c'est quand même poursuivi audion au
xviie siècle certainement peut-être au
début dé
excellent mais après ça je vois plus
haut dans ce que j'ai lus ou vous de mes
recherches
alors rassurez nous aujourd'hui il ya
plus d'un des deux guerres
ça n'existe pas tout est fait selon les
règles
est ce que vous trouvez que maintenant
trop de règles qui encadrent l'adoption
coutumière parce qu'avec une loi la loi
113 avec l'implication de la dpj est ce
qu on sort un peu de la tradition c'est
sûr avec la recherche sur au bicross
meilleur un système coutumier qui est là
et avec la loi qui a été adoptée une
adoption qui doit cadrer avec les
conditions le qui ont été énoncées dans
la main au niveau de l'adoption
coutumière est ce qu'un mec proprement
un purement coutumière il ya quand même
des bérets hxc flexible ça se fait de
façon orale puis il ya des actes ans
quittait qui sont impliqués se sait le
processus s'est beaucoup au niveau de la
famille l'aîné grand-mère qui jouaient
leur rôle de protection aussi de
sécurité par rapport à l'enfant oui on
est en 2020 il ya une loi qui est entrée
en vigueur le 1er janvier 2020 la loi
c'est 92 qui touche à la protection des
enfants est ce qui a une incidence avec
les adoptions dans cette loi je
réfléchis je me dis que cette loi le
lacet 92 si elle est finalement fonction
québec ça c'est une autre histoire
oui on est rendu là x est contestée par
le gouvernement de la cagd week pour
l'instant c'est c'est sur de la glace
mais je me dis que si elle vient à
entrer en fonction cette loi le permet
ou alors qu des systèmes comme on
retrouve le système d'intervention
attikameks qui va permettre aux enfants
de demeurer dans des familles
autochtones en particulier donc c'est
une des choses qu'elle peut favoriser
cette loi là
on parlait tout à l'heure que souvent
les enfants autochtones doivent être je
devrais pas déporter mais emmenés loin
de leur communauté dans des familles qui
sont allochtone et là ils vont perdre
leurs coutumes leurs traditions leur
langue et cetera
donc cette fois là qui permet disons que
cette rétention d'enfants là au sein de
leur propre communauté ou de leurs
propres nations ou d'autres communautés
autochtones
j'imagine va favoriser l'adoption que
lumière à long terme
j'imagine mais là je serai pas me dire
mais j'aurais aimé me semble que c'est
un pas dans la bonne direction si on est
grâce après oui c'est ça ça vient
reconnaître si reconnaître ça vient
juste confirmé que les nénés groupes
autochtones peuvent adopter leurs
propres lois peuvent élaborer puis
négocié un accord de coordination avec
les provinces et territoires depuis que
l'accord peut être concédées va être
considérée comme une l'autonomie
gouvernementale
oui ça touche je pense qu'il ya une
disposition qui touche qui concerne
l'adoption coutumière ou si le coeur que
les communautés y ont leur propre
système pi 2 on peut le travailler le 7
août de revaloriser revitaliser mais les
traditions jamais été suffisant de toute
façon on va en parler la semaine
prochaine en fait en semaine prochaine
on va faire notre émission un petit peu
plus tôt que d'habitude ce sera le
mercredi le mercredi à 12h15 on aura
cette émission en facebook live et on va
parler de ses 92 3 et d'en comprendre
tous les tenants tous les aboutissants
parce que ces vastes ses larges et c'est
important de comprendre où est ce qu'on
va avec lacets 92 et donc l'émission
sera en direct le mercredi mais reprise
le vendredi à la même heure au même
endroit vous allez pouvoir la suivre le
vendredi 6 et dans vos habitudes
on parlait de parce que des attikameks
vous
ce avait pris beaucoup de choses en main
en ce qui concerne la protection des
enfants entre autres on parlait la 2s aa
donc comment on dit déjà services
d'intervention le système d'un tati
québec c'est quoi exactement
ben c'est sûr ça y est c'est plus pour
contrer le placement des enfants
l'expérience des communautés puis les
acteurs attikameks qui ont amorcé un
processus menant dans les années 1995 94
pour prendre en charge le placement des
enfants y ont décidé d'adopter une
politique sociale puis de travailler
d'essayer d'aller chercher la question
dans le système de protection la
jeunesse pour pouvoir mal de prendre en
charge le la protection des enfants
masaya un peu à la manière qui sait son
prix puis c'est sûr à côté il y avait
tout dans le processus de négociation
territoriale en attendant les ja oui de
signer le traité sera l'autonomie
gouvernementale bagnon miser sur le
développement du système masia alors
donc quand vous étiez chef du conseil de
la nation des attikameks vous avez eu à
travailler sur ce dossier là pour le
développer pour le faire avancer aussi
injustement on sait avant on avait
décidé de négocier une entente en
attendant avec le québec
ça fait quand même plusieurs années
qu'on travaille pour faire qui qui
travaillait pour faire reconnaître le
régime particulier qui avait été
développé dans ce cas cadeau à ce moment
là et on note quand même commencer à
négocier l'entente avec le québec
ça c'est signé lieu de l'année parfois
oui c'est ça c'est assez récent la wii
est ce que vous êtes à l'avant garde en
tout cas en ce qui concerne ce dossier
là parmi les différentes nations
autochtones balle
la prise en charge je pourrais dire oui
on a pu en aux médias des personnes des
communautés puis intervenir aussi avec
des baies intervenants de chaque des
communautés atikamekw hymne dachy l'uci
mais c'est sûr il ya eu la chance de
recherche sur le pluralisme juridique
parce qu'on voulait justement unibal
évalué mois le système si ça ça cadrait
bien avec la vision ou pas lol comment
les les attikameks voyelles leur
autonomie leur autodétermination par
rapport à la protection des jeunes oui
je pense que les gens aujourd'hui voir
peur que c'est différent il ya quand
même des choses ça lui a permis de
travailler sur certaines choses mais je
pense qu'il ya encore des choses à
regarder a amené plus selon la vision
parce que c'est le système est implanté
donc depuis un an à peine alors y est
déjà implanté en fonte idiote
oui avec ça depuis plusieurs années oui
c'est vrai mais c'est avec l'entente
bevaisanne permis d'aller chercher du
financement oui on va en parler de toute
façon la semaine prochaine puisque on
essaie d'avoir ici sur ce plateau
quelqu'un du sii a alors sonné merkel
quelqu'un strada pour bien également
voir comment comment ça va fonctionner
avec la loi c'est 92 là comment on peut
toujours appliqué tout ça dernière
question pour cet homme va votre jeune
enfant adopté grâce à l'adoption
coutumière ali tout jeune à deux ans
deux ans et demi vous voyez c'est quoi
le futur pour cet enfant là en fait vous
avez trois enfants adoptés mais comment
vous voyez leur futur à ces enfants là
mais moi je vois comme les leaders de
demain dans leurs propres communautés
j'espère que ça va tu as défend bien de
qui qu'ils sont
des jeunes femmes inuit qui vont changer
un peu qu'ils vont emporter la fierté
peut apporter ce que je veux c'est que
je veux que mes enfants plus donner le
meilleur du monde de même pas prendre
puis redonner à la communauté parce que
c'est important dans l'enquêté pour
quoique faut pas se le cacher un
pourquoi que l'ama biologique allait
décider que de me donner son enfance et
avec toutes les problématiques qui a
dans un grand nuage repos oui donc ça
aussi donc c'est de changer tout ça puis
j'espère que justement mes filles je
vais leur donner tous les outils
nécessaires pour que les études pour que
justement il soit fier d'eux qu'ils sont
minimes le sera donné à la communauté
exemple bravooo et va vous allez
terminer votre maîtrise et vous êtes
professeur maintenant à l'université en
fait vous allez commencer à être
professeur devant vos courses ça va
porter sur quoi exactement pour les gens
qui voudraient s'inscrire
oui bah ça s'emboîte pour tradition
juridique autochtones sensibiliser les
étudiants qui vont à qui fondent et des
cours qui embarquent dans le programme
de droit qu'il ya d'autres façons de
faire de deauville le droit parce que
finalement n'est ce que je vois avec nez
des recherches que j'ai faite c'est que
le système coutumier le système
juridique traditionnelle celle du droit
convient c'est du droit vivant donc un
cours qui va s'adresser autant aux
autochtones connaught octobre évidemment
exactement videmment bonne chance en
tout cas il faut le monter maintenant le
court alors je vous laisse y allez allez
faire ce travail là merci merci beaucoup
à tout les 3 isabelle picard que nous
retrouverons mercredi prochain donc je
vous dis c'est à 12h15 mercredi prochain
en reprise vendredi prochain sur la loi
c'est 92 top crème qui est gestionnaire
à la stm la société de transport de
montréal merci beaucoup
eva ottawa merci beaucoup merci et bonne
chance à tous dans vos dans vos projets
et merci à vous d'avoir encore une fois
été là cette semaine on se retrouve donc
mercredi prochain 12h15 au revoir
[Musique]